Ben: Hello, I'm Ben Wattenberg.
A constitutional amendment to balance the
budget is a key item in the Republican contract
with America.
The House of Representatives recently passed
it now the debate moves to the Senate.
But do we really need to change the U.S. Constitution
to get our books in order?
How important is a balanced budget?
And is there a political agenda behind the
debate?
Joining us to sort through the conflict and
the consensus are four leading economists
from San Francisco via satellite Milton Friedman,
Nobel laureate in economics and senior research
fellow at the Hoover Institution.
Herbert Stein, Chairman of the Council of
Economic Advisers under Presidents Nixon and
Ford, and a senior fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute.
James Miller, Budget Director for President
Reagan and John M. Olin Distinguished Fellow
at the Center for the Study of Public Choice
at George Mason University.
And Henry Aaron, Director of Economic Studies
at the Brookings Institution, and a former
chairman of the Advisory Council on Social
Security.
The topic before this house, the budget-balancing
act.
This week on "Think Tank."
One of the most common stories in the economic
profession concerned President Truman, who
after hearing so many economists tell him,
on the one hand this, and on the other hand
that, turned to his staff and growled, "Find
me a one-armed economist," and they're probably
still out looking.
In the 1980s, the federal deficit went way
up and stayed up.
According to the budget just introduced by
the Clinton administration, in 1995 the government
will spend $193 billion more than it will
take in and the deficit will continue at about
that level into the future.
Moreover, critics say Congress won't stop
this trend because Congress is out of control.
House Republicans say the best way to rein
in spending is to pass a constitutional amendment
that will force Congress to balance the budget
by the year 2002.
What they're saying is, "Stop me before I
kill again."
But is the deficit really so bad?
For the nation as a whole, the deficit as
a share of our gross domestic product is heading
down.
So on the one hand, things don't look so bad.
In fact, some Democrats say that the crusade
for a balanced budget amendment is really
just a smokescreen for a conservative ideology
that wants to strangle government by cutting
off its oxygen, that is, its ability to spend.
But on the other hand, look at this, the Bipartisan
Commission on Entitlement and Tax Reform projects
that unless changes are made, the deficit
will soar to 19% of our gross domestic product
by the year 2030, and that would be a handful.
Milton Friedman in San Francisco via satellite,
do we need a balanced budget amendment?
Milton: We need a strong balanced budget amendment
such as was proposed in the Contract for America
with a tough tax limitation provision.
We do not need the kind of weak balanced budget
amendment that was actually passed by the
Congress.
Ben: Okay, Herbert Stein.
Herbert: Well, I think you're gonna find that
you need some two-handed economists here because
I don't think we need a balanced budget amendment
either.
of either kind.
I think our record, except for a brief spree
during the Reagan period, was not so bad.
I think we are learning to do better.
And I think that we will do better without
the amendment than with it.
Ben: Henry Aaron.
Henry: I think we need to balance the budget.
I think we can balance the budget, in fact,
by the year 2002.
But I think a balanced budget amendment will
do absolutely nothing to help us along the
way and will, in short order, be the source
of incentives for gimmickry.
It will bring the courts into budget policy
in a way that I think everybody should deplore.
And in short, I think the Balanced Budget
Amendment will stand in our way rather than
help us on the road to sound budget policy.
Ben: Jim Miller.
James: I disagree with all three of my colleagues
here.
I think we need a balanced budget amendment,
though I would support the one that Milton
was talking about.
I don't think we ought to cast this one away.
I think it would have some good effects some
research that I've done with Mark Crane suggests
that.
On the other hand, I think it would have an
effect.
It's not that it would just be gimmickry.
I think the result would be that it would
put discipline on members of Congress, the
sort of discipline that they sorely need.
Ben: But does...
Go ahead.
Herbert: Well, it kind of assumes that this
discipline will be in the direction of getting
us a better budget policy.
Now, there is no reason to think that the
best of all budget policies is to balance
the budget every year or every decade or every
generation.
We're not gonna have the best of all budget
policies anyway, with or without the amendment.
The question is whether, without the amendment,
we will have a chance of coming closer?
And I think we will because the economy fluctuates,
cyclically, demography changes, other requirements
change.
And the Balanced Budget Amendment is gonna
prevent us from making rationalize adaptations
to these changes in the economy.
Milton: I don't believe that's correct.
The balance...the amendment as it was originally
proposed did not rule out temporary deficits
or surpluses.
It did not require a balanced budget every
year.
The issue, however, is not being, it seems
to me, presented correctly.
The key issue is not balancing the budget.
The key issue is how do you keep spending
from growing at an intolerable rate?
As of today, governments, federal, state and
local spend about 43% of the national income
we're not getting our money's worth.
And the trouble with a weak Balanced Budget
Amendment, which is why I am against it, is
that it will tend to drive Congress.
It will be just, it will have discipline as
Jim says, but will tend to exert that discipline
in the way of higher taxes rather than lower
spending.
Henry: If that's what you believe Milton,
then I think you should make your case to
the American public, and try and win it in
a straight up fight in a democratic system,
not shackle the budgetary process with rules
that are really not made for the next year
or the next five years but for decades.
Ben: But Henry, let me ask you this.
We have rarely had an election, certainly
in a congressional year where the issues were
at least allegedly nationalized.
Now, Gingrich went around with that Contract
for America, and he said, "This is what we're
voting on."
Herbert: Oh, but...
Ben: Well, wait a minute that's what he said.
I know there's a lot of flaws in there but
he said...
Henry: But 30% of the public had never heard
of the contract and most of those who had
heard of it didn't know what it said.
Milton: But this is...
Henry: So it's not a...that wasn't even an
example of a nationalization.
Let me say the reason I think good conservatives
should be really upset at the prospect of
a balanced budget amendment, as many conservatives
are, such as Robert Bork, the editorial board
of the "Wall Street Journal."
Is that if we enact such an amendment, it
is going to threaten I think one of the great
strengths of the American economy, that conservatives
would correctly pride.
Compared to European nations, we have less
government spending, we are less bureaucratic,
we have fewer regulations.
It may be the case that we are in the midst
of a conservative era currently, in a few
years there may be a more activist mood in
Congress, what would be the easiest thing
in the world to do?
Well, mandate, that private business, do the
things that government now spends, pay unemployment
insurance benefits, pay retirement benefits,
provide sickness benefits.
One could, in other words, replace, because
of the restrictions of a balanced budget amendment,
the tendency when there is a consensus about
public need for government to spend money
and raise taxes, with regulations, and mandates.
Ben: And here you're talking about what good
conservatives should believe, you certainly
have credentials as a good conservative.
James: Right.
But we're doing that already.
That is to say that offloading to mandates
on state and local governments and on the
private sector, I mean, Milton's point about
43% if you add regulation in there, Milton,
you get more like 50%.
Herbert: It's more, over 50% [crosstalk 00:11:15]
Henry: [crosstalk 00:11:15] with 34%, according
to the OECD.
[crosstalk 00:11:19].
Ben: Let Milton come in from San Francisco
for a minute.
Milton.
Milton: I think this is much of this is beside
the point.
In the first place so far as the public at
large voting on it.
I'm making my case in the public the Balanced
Budget Amendment will only become part of
the Constitution if it's accepted by three-quarters
of the states.
That's surely a chance for the public to express
their opinion on it we're not trying to slip
anything over.
In the second place, I wanna emphasize, and
I'm not a conservative.
I'm a liberal in the good old fashioned sense
of a 19th-century liberal, more likely a libertarian.
And as such, what I wanna do and what I believe
the public at large wants to do is in Reagan's
phrase, "Get the government off the back of
the people."
And the only way you can do that is by having
some kind of a limit on government spending.
That's the purpose of requiring a 60% majority
for a tax.
James: I think Milton is exactly right.
One important and if not the most important
effect of the Balanced Budget Amendment would
be to circumscribe the growth of government.
Mark Crane and I did some analysis of state
regulatory institutions, some states have
balanced budget requirements in the Constitution,
some have it as a matter of law, some do not
have it.
There are all sorts of different variations.
We used as the dependent variable growth per
capita spending in the state.
What we found Milton, and Herb and Henry is
that a balanced budget requirement restrains
the growth of spending in the States, and
this happens without regard to whether there
is a supermajority requirement for a tax increase.
Herbert: But the public and the political
process are gonna have to make a lot of very
difficult decisions about the budget.
Decisions about the budget, that are as important
as the total size of the budget, or the size
of the deficit, they have to decide what is
appropriate defense policy?
What is appropriate welfare policy?
What is appropriate health policy?
And these questions cannot be resolved by
a constitutional amendment, and they are no
different from the question about the total
size of the budget.
Ben: Right.
James: But the...
Milton: I believe they are...
James: But the balanced budget amendment would
enforce...
Ben: Hold on, one second I wanna just shift
gears for a moment to help our audience out.
Let me put this question in the pot.
Are deficits, really bad, running deficits,
year after year after year?
Herbert: Well, I don't think you can answer
that question, because it depends on what
you're doing with the money that you raised
through the deficit.
And of course, it's kind of, other things
equal, I think little deficits are a little
bad and big deficits are big bad, but I wouldn't...there
are certainly circumstances for which it is
entirely appropriate to run a deficit.
James: Herb is right.
I mean, in a perfect world you would run surpluses
sometimes, you would run deficit sometimes,
Herb invented the full employment surplus
or balanced budget full employment with the
automatic stabilizers.
And all of that is...works.
The question though, is we're not in a perfect
world would it make sense to prevent the politicians
in Washington from using deficit finance?
Ben: Jim, we've just elected your kind of
people we elected a Jim Miller, Milton Friedman,
kind of Congress and you don't trust them?
James: I don't trust them.
Milton: Well, look at what's happened.
Ben: Hold it.
You ran for Senate in the primary in Virginia
against Oliver North, you almost beat him.
James: Right.
Ben: Would you trust you if you were there?
James: Of course, I would trust me [inaudible
00:14:51]
Ben: But you don't trust your republican conservative
colleagues.
Henry: I would trust him too.
James: I don't trust the institution.
Herbert: But I think that we ought to have
a surplus now.
But when I asked myself, "Should we have a
surplus now?"
I say, "Yes, it would be desirable.
And it would be desirable because I can think
of $300 or $400 billion worth of spending
that's in the budget, that I would be willing
to get rid of in order to have the surplus.
Ben: Like what?
Herbert: Well, I would get rid of Medicare
I would cut Medicaid down very sharply.
I would start phasing out Social Security
I would get rid of foreign price supports.
I would get rid of the small business administration.
Henry: And you won't get elected.
Herbert: Well, I...
Ben: Jim you wanna run on that platform?
You're a conservative...
James: I wanna make a lot of changes.
Maybe not all the changes.
Milton: Well, look, let's stop that.
If you go after each one of those individually,
you will not get elected.
James: Right.
Milton: If you go after them as a bundle that's
a different thing.
I believe the views of the American public
tend to be misunderstood.
If you ask the public, do you wanna cut social
security?
They'll say no.
But if you ask them, "Would you rather eliminate
the deficit by cutting spending or by increasing
taxes?"
They overwhelmingly say they wanna cut spending.
Herbert: Well, we've asked them now since
1936, we've been asking them in public opinion
polls, do you wanna balance the budget?
They always say, overwhelmingly, no.
And they always overwhelmingly elect people
who never did balance the budget, and he gave
no sign of ever wanting to balance the budget.
I don't think the American people really care
very much about balancing the budget.
Ben: Right.
[crosstalk 00:16:23].
Ben: Let me...hold it we have...
Milton: Could I interject one point?
Ben: Yeah, go ahead.
Milton: We had...we may not have balanced
the budget to the nickel from 1945 until 1974
the ratio of the U.S. debt to our productive
capacity declined by more than half.
Herbert: That was the year I left the government.
Ben: That was the year Herbert left the government.
Herbert: [inaudible 00:16:43]
James: It was then...no, it was because we
were running deficits that were much smaller
than the growth of the economy.
If the deficits had been large, it would have
grown, and what happened was it then leveled
off until 1981 these are facts, Milton.
Milton: I know.
James: And then in 1981, we entered an era
where we cut taxes, raised spending, and really
lied to the American public about the probable
fiscal consequences.
Ben: Right.
Milton.
Milton: The debt declined as a fraction of
income, not because we ran small surpluses,
small deficits.
But because we inflated the debt away, we
repudiated a large fraction of the debt.
We were paying interest rates on the debt,
which was below the rate of inflation.
That's how the debt was reduced.
Henry: All right.
Let me talk about something that maybe I know
something about, which is public opinion,
which you all learned economists have discussed.
And politics, I've been around Washington
long enough to say, you know, what is the
hidden agenda?
And it's not even very hidden in this discussion.
Milton Friedman says he doesn't care if the
budget is balanced.
He doesn't like government.
He says the government is picking your pocket.
So why are you arguing?
I mean, isn't this being somewhat deceitful
is to say, "We're talking, this is good for
the economy, it's good for this, it's good
for that."
In fact, why don't you get out there and say,
"Government is bad for us, and this is what
we're talking about not a balanced budget
amendment, this is a political agenda."
James: Well, look, I mean, you have too much
government.
I think that's what the election was about
balancing the budget is a very appealing to
people it will have the effect, as Milton
said of restraining the avarice of the federal
government.
And I think that's good.
Ben: I thought Herbert was saying that you
can use the Balanced Budget Amendment, or
Henry, to go up?
James: I don't think that's correct.
Herbert: But I think the answer is, to your
question, is that we have a responsibility
to tell the American people what their choices
are.
And if we think that the government...I believe,
to say the government is too big by itself
is really meaningless without specifying what
the government is doing.
But I think we should confront the American
people with this choice.
Do you want Medicare?
Do you want Social Security?
Do you want this or that?
Ben: All right.
Milton, he says, it doesn't matter the level
of government.
What do you say?
Milton: I'm saying, Herbert what you're saying
is not fair.
Those of us who have been...who think government
has been doing too much have specified over
and over again, what we think needs to be
done.
Have over and over again, urged, for example,
privatization of Social Security, so that
it's not fair to criticize us on the ground
that we haven't...
Herbert: I'm not criticizing you, Milton,
but I'm just criticizing all these people
in the congress who have never said anything
like that.
Milton: Well, that may well be.
Henry: I think it's also important you mentioned
public opinion, Ben.
Ben: I mentioned it because you all mentioned
it.
Henry: Yes.
Well, okay.
The American public has consistently said
they want lower taxes and a balanced budget.
They have also said when asked about specific
activities of government that they want to
maintain or even expand, everything that they're
asked specifically about with two exceptions
welfare and foreign aid.
Ben: Right.
So public opinion in this field is mush.
Henry: It's inconsistent.
Ben: It's mush.
Milton: It's not.
Henry: It's inconsistent.
Ben: Milton, why not?
Milton: The questions that are asked, because
the questions that are asked...
Ben: They say two things.
Milton: No, excuse me for a moment.
If you ask a person, do you want to eliminate
one thing which he benefits from, the rational
answer is no.
But if you give him a package, if you give
him a bundle, and say, "Do you want... the
only way we can cut government is by cutting
a lot of things."
We had that example in connection with the
closing of the military bases you couldn't
get anyone closed when you tr to get it alone.
When you had a package of it, ala Dick Armey's
proposal, you got bases closed.
Ben: Let me ask you this.
Henry, I mean, I just asked the conservatives,
Jim Miller, and Milton Friedman, whether they...
Henry: I'm not a conservative.
Ben: I'm sorry the conservative and libertarian
faction of this panel, whether they weren't
really promoting a not so hidden agenda.
They weren't just talking about the budget
amendment, but they were talking about, they
would like to defund the welfare state.
And this is one way to do it.
And my sense is that the politics on the other
side, you're all talking about, well, it would
be hard to adjust it and hard to regulate,
and sometimes we ought to have a deficits.
But you guys wanna keep the welfare state
and you have to have high spending to do it.
Is that the political agenda over there?
Herbert: It's not the case.
It's not my case, of course, the welfare state
is a very vague term.
And I would like to confine welfare to a very
small fraction of the American population
that is really poor, and get rid of all the
welfare that goes to the American middle class,
or about which everybody is now bleeding.
So I'm not for the welfare state in the general
sense.
But my agenda, I guess, really, is to have
a rational national discussion about what
our alternatives are in the open and offer
the American...and I think that we are capable
of learning to do better.
And I would give the example of last year's
debate about health care reform.
I think that was a case in which the options
were fairly clearly laid out, and in which
we did not make the same mistakes that we
made 20 or 30 years earlier, by making enormous
commitments to the future.
I think we are showing the great gain and
the prudence and responsibility of our fiscal
policy.
And I think...so I'm hopeful that we will
continue to do that.
James: But Herb and Henry, I think that a
balanced budget amendment would force people
to make those kinds of choices.
Our politicians, as representatives of the
people, would have to weigh and assess the
alternatives rather than offloading the burden
on future generations because of fiscal illusion.
Henry: Yeah, actually, a balanced budget amendment
doesn't force any member of Congress to vote
against any public expenditure or in favor
of any tax.
James: But it forces them to discuss it and
resolve it in some way.
Henry: No, it doesn't even do that.
They can, if they wish, ignore the amendment.
And if they do so you will have a situation
where somebody will take it to court, and
the Supreme Court will be setting budget policy
for the United States.
James: Not under current circumstances...
Henry: That's the only way.
James: Anyone that spends beyond the limit
is in violation of federal law.
Henry: Oh, absolutely, who judges?
James: It's a violation of the anti-deficiency
law and they go to jail.
Henry: Oh, no.
Herbert: Who is that?
James: The members of the Congress who are
an agency head that authorizes spending beyond
the limit.
Ben: I can see on the monitor that Milton
wants to come in from San Francisco.
Milton: Yes, you're right.
I do not believe it will go to the courts
I believe a properly drawn up balanced budget
amendment will put the power in the hands
of the Congress and the President between
them.
And that you're not going to have all of this
nonsense that's being talked about.
[crosstalk 00:23:27]
Milton: What I don't understand, I wanna ask
those who are opposed to the Balanced Budget
Amendment, whether they think it's inappropriate
for the public at large, to set a limit on
the fraction of their income that government
is entitled to spend?
Henry: Absolutely not.
I think it is entirely proper, we have an
electoral process that is perfectly suited
to do that now.
Milton: It is not, it is suited to do it on
a piecemeal basis, but not on an overall basis.
Herbert: Whether it's appropriate for the
people of 1995, to decide for the people of
2095 what proportion of their income should
go to the government.
And I don't think that's appropriate.
We're talking about forever now if we talk
about a constitutional amendment, and that
I think is what this...
Milton: Would you think it would be wrong
for the people in 1995, to specify that the
federal...governments at all levels should
never spend 100% of the national income?
Ben: Henry.
Henry: I would just point out that Milton
is once again discussing something that is
not before the American public.
What is before the American public is an amendment
he himself has said is not well designed,
and that he himself would oppose, he's discussing
a different agenda not the one that is before
the American public today, which is the amendment
that the House of Representatives approved.
Ben: Milton.
All right, go ahead, Milton.
Milton: That isn't so because the Senate still
has to come in.
And in my opinion, I'm opposed to the present
one, because I think if you turn this down,
there will be enough of an outcry about turning
it down because of the tax limitation proposal,
that within two or three or four months, you'd
have a proper balanced budget amendment passed.
I do not think the public at large is opposed
to a 60% majority rule for taxes.
James: I don't think they are either.
But I, on the other hand, I don't think that
you're going to get the two-thirds vote in
both houses that you have to have to put the
amendment before the states with the tax limitation
in it.
I wish that were not the case, I would like
to even strengthen the amendment further by
putting a restraint on the proportion of gross
national product that government may spend,
but that wish is not going to come to fruition,
I'm afraid.
Henry: Just to go back to the point that Herb
made.
My colleague Charles Schulz has pointed out
that the founding fathers when dealing with
matters of human rights, stated them with
great specificity, put them in the constitution
and defined them exactly.
In discussing procedures that would be used
inside the government they laid down hard
and fast rules.
But when it came to setting economic policies
such as the share of gross domestic product
that should go to government, they said nothing.
They understood that these are the kinds of
issues that need to be resolved in each generation,
through the political process by elected officials.
I don't think we would want Thomas Jefferson
setting an economic policy for our age, we
would not want Alexander Hamilton setting
it.
Ben: Right.
James: But could I just say, first of all,
never in their wildest dreams would they think
of a government as large as we have today.
And secondly, Mr. Jefferson, before he died,
wrote a friend and said he thought perhaps
the biggest mistake in the constitution was
allowing deficit finance.
Ben: Okay, thank you, Milton Friedman, Herbert
Stein, Jim Miller, and Henry Aaron.
And thank you.
Please send your comments and questions to
New River Media, 1150 17th Street, Northwest,
Washington, DC 20036.
Or we can be reached via email at thinktv@aol.com.
For "Think Tank," I'm Ben Wattenberg.
Announcer: This has been a production of BJW
incorporated in association with New River
Media which are solely responsible for its
content.